we're the first company in 11 years who
has said no to the Consumer Product
Safety Commission we're not going to
recall the product
hey it's Kennedy for reason TV here in
the buckyballs headquarters this is the
CEO of buckyballs worldwide Craig Zucker
thank you very much what is your exact
title I am CEO and co-founder the
company at the name is Maxfield no
Burton well congratulations
except for the part where the federal
government is breathing down your neck
when did the feds first get in touch
with you about three months ago
they started looking into rare earth
magnets the industry evaluating
competitors warnings and again we were
working very closely with them to make
sure that giving them information and
sharing our sales and what we were doing
and on July 25th they filed a lawsuit an
administrative complaint and sued us to
stop selling our products ban the
product and go out of business that's
horrible I mean obviously you've been
working you have rigorous safety
standards you have safety warnings on
all of your packaging why now there was
a small number of incidents of children
getting their hands on the balls
misusing the product sadly and
unfortunately if they're swallowed they
have the ability to perforate intestines
pinched intestine see they want to find
each other they're really strong right
they're not your average refrigerator
magnet the government does have an
obligation to help create standards
right reasonable standards though
manufacturers have to take those
standards follow them and educate
consumers but consumers do have to
follow the the warnings and the
regulations that we share with them and
in this case it's to keep them away from
children to keep them away from the nose
and mouth to not swallow or ingest them
and our packaging has five warnings on
it repeatedly we don't sell to stores
that sell only children's products so we
don't sell the toy stores do you take
other let's just take other products out
there right like balloons right
fireworks button batteries they're loons
are deadly there's been there's 10:10
death since 2007 right hundreds of kids
go to the hospital every year from
suffocating Association and the remedy
for
balloons is a warning on the packaging
and the federal government has said now
warnings don't work and so the remedy
for thousands and thousands of other
products that they regulate Consumer
Product Safety Commission is warnings
education awareness campaigns and so for
the first time they said it doesn't work
anymore and you are fighting back
we are fighting back we're the first
company in eleven years who has said no
to the Consumer Product Safety
Commission the first time the company
has said we're not going to recall the
products so now we get our day in court
and it's it it's referred to
administrative law judge and we'll fight
we'll fight it and we're gonna fight
vigorously well I think a lot of people
are addicted to your balls and I know
that you've got the save our balls
campaign how is that going so are 5,000
retailers are intimidated they're
bullied
the CPSC sends letters they intimidate
them so what has happened is the save
our balls campaign has brought
individual consumers online back to our
site and we're actually doing more in
sales now through our website and
through social media and through
everything that's been happening than we
did in 5,000 stores leading up to what
CPSC did well hopefully this will be a
marketing boost for you guys we know
this is nonsense as a parent I wouldn't
give my kids buckyballs but then again I
also don't let them swim in a pool
unattended right yeah I mean look I have
a dog
I've nieces and nephews I have children
that come over I don't have buckyballs
at the hat in my home when they come
over and I think that there is a level
of personal responsibility that comes
into play when it comes to consumer
product safety Kraig Zucker buckyballs
CEO a man of his word leave him alone
government Thank You Craig thank you
very much for recent TV I'm Kennedy